what's up ladies and gentlemen we're
going to continue our ritual of covering
spider warren's videos with major
spider-man no way home
news and leaks but speaking of rituals
we got a sponsorship that we were
supposed to post earlier this week
so today we're sponsored by you guessed
it vitamins
john tell them all about ritual ritual
is a 2017 british horror film about five
friends who meet at a pub
that's not it what kind of rituals does
ritual specialize in you ask
celebration healing satan john your
health is not a laughing matter despite
how funny you are
you should be trying ritual oh getting
personal well obsessively researched and
transparently produced multivitamins are
my favorite food group that's perfect
you said perfect things because rituals
essentials for men contain
10 high quality nutrients like vitamin a
d omega-3s and
zinc which can be tough to get in your
regular diet john and as someone who's
had these vitamins recommended to me is
real
specifically in real life this is great
rituals is a 1977 horror movie directed
by peter carter and his about five ducks
did you know rituals bottles are made
with a hundred percent recycled
materials they're dedicated to
sustainability
every step of the way they even use
plant-based
inks rituals sent us the essential
vitamins for men but they also offer
multivitamins for women
teens and mothers i have a mother i have
a teenage daughter
they're sugar gluten and allergen free
and non-gmo
they're even freaking vegan plus if
you're looking for a way to build up
your body which you should definitely do
john we've got an all-new protein range
to help you build and maintain lean
muscle mass
i could definitely benefit off that but
you you
you should you should definitely
definitely use it and they're
transparent with their practices so you
can see what goes into your vitamins
every step of the way it's only a dollar
a day to have the essentials delivered
to your door but when you hit up
our special link and use our code that
you can see here that i know offhand at
checkout you'll receive 10
off your ritual order for the first
thres months
so fill in the gaps in your diet so you
don't have to look like john the right
is a 2011 horror movie starring anthony
hopkins
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some pretty big spider-man
news not only just
news in general but also some leaks that
we have to go over
leaks basically confirming the spider
verse news basically confirming the
spider-verse and a statement from
michael waldron the head writer of the
loki series again
basically confirming the spider-verse
this really
really is hollywood's worst kept secret
at this point and maybe that's why they
haven't released the trailer yet and no
sadly i have not heard any updates about
the spider-man no way home trailer i
believe that trailer is going to come
out at cinemacon the end of august
because sodi did say that they are
going to have a presentation there where
they're going to
unveil stuff from their upcoming
projects and then it's a week before
shang chi so it could play theaters with
shock chi but then again this is a story
that is you replace a couple of words
and it sounds like the same thing we've
said a bunch of times
just replace cinemacon for the next
event yeah play shock cheap with a
different movie yeah
but in this video i'll tell you all the
new stuff that i have learned and do
know
and if you love spider-man and marvel be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
so let's start off by talking about
spider-man no way home
reshoots now if you've been following my
channel or you've just been looking
online you probably have known that
spider-man reshoots have been happening
for about a week or maybe a week and a
half now so this isn't really news
however what the news is is that they
are actually doing the reshoots in la
and over the past couple of days guess
who has gotta go find the set
all three different spider-mans and
kristen dunst
all of them over the past couple of days
have been spotted in
la and that's no coincidence since they
are doing reshoots in la so of course
that leads us to believe that they are
all in la to do reshoots for spider-man
no way home
it's actually kind of funny tom holland
was spotted going to a suicide squad
premiere
and based off of everything i've heard
that movie is fantastic so i don't blame
him at all
andrew garfield has 100 been spotted in
la so has toby maguire but there has
been sort of a controversial picture
that i want to clear up
kristen dunst was spotted with a woman
that people claimed was deborah ann wall
it's not on page about this was
in l.a so a lot of people thought okay
so she's going to be in the movie
because matt murdock is going to be
peter parker's lawyer in the beginning
of the film so this makes sense
however deborah and wool actually
commented on the photo and said that's
not me
i'm not the werewolf expect charlie cox
matt murdock to be
in the film i don't expect karen page
now that you said
i'm not the werewolf that would be
pretty cool i know right but we did see
this
woman with kirsten dunst somewhere else
is
yeah as it turns out this is just one of
kristen dunst's friends
however when the reshoots were announced
charlie cox did have to cancel going to
a comic con
and considering all the reports that
he's in the movie that is probably why
he had the cancel to go do some reshoots
and i just want to add that jacob battle
on the way
as well so basically the whole rumored
cast
is in la right now and spider-man
reshoots are happening in
la maybe a couple of them together there
at the same time could be a coincidence
but this is like all of them so i'm
gonna say this is not a coincidence and
it's definitely for reshoots
let's be fair most of them have a home
in los angeles yeah i know
like maybe they all finally returned
back this is the capital of filmmaking
yeah yeah and especially for like
kirsten dunst i'm like i'm pretty sure
she
the only one who i would be surprised by
is like i don't know does tom holland
live
i'm surprised we have never seen kirsten
dunst because he used to go to our
church
yeah exactly i went to the same high
school
basically tells us again that all of
them are in the film but if you need
more evidence don't worry i have more
for you in this video
let's move on to what loki head writer
michael waldron had to say
about working with the people who were
riding spider-man no way home
when writing loki michael waldron
admitted that he had to keep in contact
with the people at spider-man no way
home and the people
at doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and here's what he said about
working specifically with the people
over at spiderman no way home
your production teams are constantly
communicating with those producing teams
to make sure that you're not screwing
each other up
i had the benefit on spiderman no way
home chris mckenna and eric summers
wrote that
i was their writer's pa on season five
of community so i can call mckenna and
get bullied by him whenever i want
but also say hey what the hell are you
guys doing
let me make sure i'm not ruining it so
there's communication to the extent
that the creative teams themselves the
filmmakers the writers whoever can
become friendly it certainly benefits
the projects
so michael basically admitted right
there that while he was writing loki
he couldn't do anything to mess up what
was happening in spiderman no way home
loki was an incredible series and it's a
good thing we're getting season two
however
loki pretty much had one job introduce
the multiverse
explain the multiverse destroy that
sacred timeline
and send everything into madness say
[ __ ] all the
loki's story
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and of course long-term
secret wars now obviously spider-man no
way home is the first movie to come out
after the loki series the first movie
that connects to it at least we're not
including chung chi or the eternals here
we don't know especially the eternal
way home but again loki kind of just had
one point introduced the multiverse it's
spider-man noway home that actually has
a lot of very
calculated things happening in the film
bringing in toby maguire spider-man
andrew garfield spider-man
kirsten dunst's mj and it seems like
there are very specific things that have
to happen
for them to come into this film which is
why loki's head writer michael waldron
had to consistently check in with the
people over at spiderman no way home
and if that wasn't enough we have even
more evidence
of the spiderverse in spiderman no way
home that comes in the form
of good ol reliable toiletries
specifically the description
toy looks pretty specific so i'll just
read them and then we'll talk about them
after
and not only do these tease the spider
verse but also the sinister six the
first one reads
swing into terror with the spider-man no
way home
six-inch action figures with lots of
articulation and potentially multiversal
consequences
each figure draws its inspiration from
the movie and potentially other
movies too big tease right there we then
have one from hasbro that says
the future of reality has never been
less certain than in spider-man no way
home
what madness will be unleashed as peter
comes face to face with
unlimited possibilities just like the
possibilities of fun you'll have with
these deluxe action figures
extra action means extra fun blasting
goodness knows what through
magic new adventures another big tease
there especially because it says
unlimited possibilities but then we have
one more that reads
blast your way into another universe
with the spider-man no way home hero
blasters
these fun blasters let you bring the
movie adventures home
provided you can find a way back at this
point i think a lot of people
have considered the fact that no way
home probably is referring to people
going back to their own home universes
but as far as the spiderburst is
concerned there are some pretty big
giveaways here
the first one says potentially
multiversal consequences
and it's kind of funny that they say
potentially multiversal consequences
instead of multiversal consequences i
think this is their attempt to
kind of keep people in the dark but
again we all know but then again it says
each figure draws its inspiration from
the movie and potentially other movies
too
again why i say potentially we know it's
going to be from spider-man 1 spider-man
2
the amazing spider-man 2 and maybe even
another curveball thrown at us but still
huge indication right there italian
spicer
madness will be unleashed as peter comes
face to face with
unlimited possibilities of course when i
hear spider-man no way home and i hear
madness i think of multiverse of madness
and when you think of the multiverse you
think of unlimited possibilities
and of course there's the one for the
blaster that says blast your way into
another universe and then it even says
provided you can find a way
back as in a way back home so at this
point it's actually really hard to
believe that they haven't released the
trailer yet although i can say
this i have heard that promotion for all
of the other spider-man and the other
universes
is not going to start until about
halfway into the promotion
so based off of what i've been told we
aren't going to see toby and andrew in
the very first teaser
but that's all i have today for
spider-man no way home let me know what
you think about all of these leaks
and news in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof well if weren't
saying that they won't
see i don't think you would see them in
the first trailer
but i would imagine that what you would
probably do is at least
introduce the villains who have come out
like jamie foxx or or i mean
very minimum doc yeah yeah that'd
probably be the main thing that i
the ones that you'd see legitimately
been confirmed yeah
yeah there's a lot to uh i mean there's
a lot of villains that are supposed to
be in here i mean i think it'd be cooler
if you
just reserve that and show only them
okay and then next trailer blow
everything
just just play the prologue of spiderman
story of my life i think it would be
cool if you just hear their voices
without seeing their faces
yeah i would love like that that's as
much as that was a
joke i think that would be the perfect
way because like toby maguire has a
pretty distinctive voice and you know
andrew garfield's james dean
thing i'm sure we would get after
hearing toby mccoy
it should just be an echo
yeah and then we can bring in british
spiderman
all right guys well multiverse we know
it's here it's already begun
long ago the loki that's the end game
yeah i don't know there's so many things
there's no way this isn't in some way a
multiverse movie but guys leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button thank you warren for putting this
together last but not least
eric horseman i totally messed up i
totally put down and my messages to you
on instagram
that i am going to wish you a happy
birthday on your birthday and i did it
i got it mixed up with someone else's
birthday and i shouted that person's
birthday out
when it was your birthday so eric john
just reminded me
and i was like crap that's what it was
i'm sorry
happy birthday happy birthday you're
like the best guy ever
so sexy you're the only one with real
rejects no one buys our shirts
you're the only one who got our tattoo
that's right
painfully i'm so happy you did that i
love you man
i owe you a phone call for just messing
this one up
i'm so sorry they call you horsemen
because you got a horse
sound yeah you rock rock in another
multiverse i was
banging you on your birthday oh we were
eiffel towering you yeah you're doing so
good it's good
love you buddy i'm sorry